well welcome John it's it's great having
you here with us and we'll be hearing
from you very shortly in your
Distinguished Lecture but we take a
little time out to say hello more
informally and our fireside chat we've
put up a fire today anyway so just a
little bit maybe about your background
and how you got interested in computer
science and what did that interest come
from to start with ah let's see so i
yeah i'm i guess when interest came from
i in high school i was i think i you
sort of want to be a math major I mean
actually I from some early phase I
either want to be like a math major or a
fiction writer or a lawyer I think but
you know gradually was all sort of
coalesced toward something more
technical and also that was kind of the
era when the Apple 2 plus had just
appeared and so I you know I liked
writing programs in the Apple 2 plus I
like writing games that my friends could
play in the school library on floppy
disks and things but I somehow I didn't
imagine that that was like a field of
study I felt like this is just a hobby
that you do and so the striking thing
was when I got to college to you know
it's an undergrad at Cornell to discover
that was actually academic field of
computer science with you know some
rather inspirational faculty who were
teaching courses in it so I ended up
double majoring in math and computer
science and I think my interesting fear
science we're sort of toward the
theoretical end of things you know given
my interest in math but then you know
sort of in the mid 90s kind of 1996-97
after grad school I you know I was doing
a postdoc at IBM Almaden with provocate
Raghavan and pravakar made the argument
that you know we're just for this
amazing opportunity that there's the web
which sort of like the personal computer
in the early eighties seems like just a
glorified hobby the people are just
playing around with but there's a lot
going on here and so I began thinking
about you know questions about
organizing information on the web and
you know because with a a a Fatah and
grad school you know I had done so much
work on graph algorithms you know I
thought you know one thing I contribute
here is sort of my my understanding of
graphs and so you know think about the
link structure of the web made me
realize that actually you know you
really need to understand the human
system to understand what's going on and
so it was this
that for me was really a lot of fun that
you know there was a mathematical
aspects to think about the network
structure but then it sort of tapped
into all these other sort of fascination
sigh you know I had from early in high
school with you know narrative and law
and policy and social science and all of
that showed up in the web and that's
really understandable yet understand all
these things and so that's I think
somehow I ended up in this mix of topics
that I I find interesting yeah actually
it was a really good explanation of the
what others might see as a Venn diagram
with some interesting intersections
I remember reading um your your your
hubs and authority work talking about
Webster structure of the web back in the
90s and thinking about what this might
mean for both a science for
understanding the the admission of of
human interests and human generated
content and human interests in accessing
that content and the algorithms that we
could actually sort of used to to
capture and to optimize various kinds of
objectives yeah I'm curious to hear
about your reflection about the you know
your your maybe to describe more about
what you were doing with the hubs and
authority work and what that meant you
think for therefore the evolution of
thinking about the web I see yeah right
so I yeah I mean when I first I think
about the web it was fundamentally it
seemed like it was in information
retrieval problem on a giant tax corpus
we had put a lot of documents out there
and we want to find the documents that
have the terms that we want but but when
I began thinking about the kinds of
queries that I myself was you know
trying to solve in it and actually at
the time you know sort of summer of 96 I
was moving you know for a year to this
new place San Jose I'd never live in
California and so you know you're doing
a lot of research about like you know
where can i buy this thing for my
apartment and so you you because the on
the web and it wasn't you know it was
often the activity was to try to sort of
organize this giant mass of information
to figure out what are the good sources
and so I I began to discover a thing
that I myself was doing you know as I
sort of chase down the link structure
and tried to sort of engage in some
meta awareness of what am i doing as I
try to buy furniture for my apartment or
try to find you know you know what are
the reading groups that are meeting
about different things and it was clear
that the information about which were
the important pages was not intrinsic to
the page wasn't that the when you found
the right page it wasn't that it said
the word you wanted more often or in
bigger font or anything it was really
you only knew that it was the right
answer because of all the other things
appointed to him you know and I think
that was the argument that uh you know
links for somehow providing this crucial
evidence but the other thing that was
happening was that there really was this
two-sided nature to it because you know
there were these these good pages but
once you had found a few pages you
realized that there were these other
pages that had linked to all of them and
you sort of missed them on your first
pass but in retrospect there was this
one page that had you just listened to
it it actually had listed you know the
three things that you end up finding
interesting and it wasn't just that it
had actually listed six things so now
that I'm taking that page more seriously
I should try figure what those other
three were you know they had the top
three maybe these others we were great
also and so these were these really
powerful hub pages somebody had done the
work before you and you're following hub
yeah to create hub it was someone who
had been faced roughly the same task
that you had and had done a very good
job solving and documented their
solution so let's go back and learn from
them and so once we find the good hub
certain things now seem like better
authorities and you know and so you
think okay so they're good authorities
they're good hubs willing to authorities
you know and then at that point I think
as a computer science you think we
should deter ate this you know I mean if
we found if we have better estimates for
our authorities we should find better
estimates for our hubs and the appealing
thing is that this iteration had some
very natural structure and it sort of
exposed this kind of two sided nature to
tell all of these topics that there were
there was the thing itself and then
there were the pages that all linked to
the thing itself and in some ways served
as the glue that held it all together
some human effort to organize that's
represented and push certainly in lots
of activity on the web and then there's
a stuff that's being pointed at as
they're kind of as the gold mine the
little gold nuggets of information that
someone else was put there just because
it's the information itself exactly yeah
and you know in a way it's like you know
we could all be basketball teams for
example and we can all and we're all
unified by the fact that we all refer to
the same
basketball stars even if we never
directly interact with the basketball
stars their existence somehow serves to
create a community among us right right
and it seems that those ideas were we're
so nascent and you know in the mid to
late 90s coming in part to all the
contributions you were making in advance
of PageRank and other kinds of
structural analyses that that people now
they say are core you know what's going
on of these algorithm but a sort of at
the root of how we look at the web and
how we look at information retrieval and
indexing which is interesting now know
now lately I get a comment oh yeah
let's say the recent work you're doing I
think most recently in some ways made
last penny a couple years of course you
do many things but I've been very
fascinated to see you bring you together
policy law Social Science in issues
around fairness which have come to the
fore lately when in people with people
rightly concerned about systemic biases
and tools that might amplify them
through great use and you want to talk a
little bit about some of the criminal
justice for example yeah yeah absolutely
yeah yeah so this is something that I
started thinking about sort of around
2011 2012 and actually it began with a
series of conversations with cental Lowe
and often who's a behavioral economist
at Harvard and sandal I had been
undergrads together at at Cornell I
didn't know that yeah we actually have a
my second paper and his first paper was
actually a pod C 1993 paper that came
out of a joint class project jointly we
did in Keith Mars who was operating
systems class and I would never even
have connected Keith they both of you
thanks man yeah thanks for making that
little metal link from exactly yeah no
no it's just a feature of like we both
took this really inspiring classroom
here and just poured a lot of effort
into doing that class project for him
but you know and you know at the time
it's funny that you know
sindelle was so you know dick Saylor was
at Cornell at the time and Senate was
very excited about these ideas and
behavioral economics but and then you
know we went our separate ways
and professionally and starting our
2011-2012
really send who sort of initiative the
contact it was like you know at this
point we're really thinking about very
similar things because you know he'd
been very focused on human
decision-making and you know human
experts in high-stakes settings and we
even in low stakes settings and the
kinds of systemic errors that people
make and I was thinking about algorithms
which are decision-making entities and
we're now in these situations where we
can really ask you know what's the
interface between and it did feel like
you know around 12 in 2012 there was
sort of this missing this missing
subject where you know we had
human-computer interaction but they were
sort of emerging human machine learning
interaction right you know how do humans
interact with big data resources and the
algorithms that make predictions based
on those we shouldn't forget the human
AI interaction human probably absolutely
yeah the political one
no absolutely and I think this point and
so we we looked at domains where you
know where the situation called for a
prediction the idea being there are lots
of kind lots of decisions that human
beings make and it's a fascinating to
ask which of these can be automated
which ones can't but let's zero in on
the cases where what people are doing is
making predictions and asking what we
can learn about the human process and
also whether there are gains to be had
and so we started talking to yen's
Ludwig who's a crime policy actually a
public policy researcher at University
Chicago one of whose domains is crime
policy and he had these very interesting
datasets on judges making bail decisions
and the reason to look at bail is that
if you look at criminal justice
obviously one of the highest stakes
settings where experts are making
decisions that have enormous impact on
people's lives if you look at the
pipeline of decisions that get made
there right there decisions about arrest
decisions about pretrial detention and
bail you know that trial sentencing
parole many many things
if yes we're in that pipeline is a
person doing something that most
resembles a pure prediction task at
least according to the law that's
arguably unveil because what the law
says a judge should do in bail is to
release the person before a trial if
they believe that with high probability
they will return for their court
appearance without committing a crime in
the mean time
and they shouldn't be thinking about
their eventual guilt or innocence they
shouldn't be thinking about what's the
incentive effect of my decision on
future defendants you should be making
that prediction now there's a whole
important set of questions about are
they making you know exactly that that
prediction but this is at least a case
where we could come in with the data
that we have and trailers in that so
this was an appealing problem I roped in
here I let's go back to my former
postdoc and his student team he melaka
raju who's graduating right now and he's
a former intern here at microsoft
research really appreciated sharing his
intellect it ya know I mean he's been
you know his pleasure to work with over
now and and so the five of us set off on
this on this project which actually took
a number of years I mean we really
started this in summer is really got
going with the five of us in summer of
2013 and and so there were a lot of
challenges here that you know so as you
said you know one challenge is that the
data is biased right so if you think
about this is a prediction problem there
are features and there's a label so the
features are maybe the administrative
data that we have on past arrests for
what types of crimes past convictions
what was the status of the person at the
time of the arrest you know information
that the algorithm is able to see in
some kind of tabular form and then the
label is if they got released did they
return for their court appearance
without without committing a crime on
the feature side of course you know the
administrative data is contaminated by
the incredibly differential rates of
policing and in different areas and so
you know an arrest is not assuming the
same thing in all different areas and
per unit level of crime it doesn't mean
the same things and that that that
becomes a big issue it's very much in
the spirit of what people worry about
when we say we're taking you know biases
that already came in you know he
predated this moment in the courtroom on
the label this notion of predicting
crime while they're released we don't
really have a crime we have a label out
arrest all we can really do is see if
they were arrested even failure to
appear has a lot of correlation with
with socioeconomic status and so there
are issues both on the kind of input end
and on the output then there are the
methodological challenges and the the
biggest one that we faced was the fact
that if the judge releases someone we
can see what happened if the judge
detained some for a trial we don't know
what would have happened to me that
could've been
it's was a kind of factual argument
exactly a counterfactual argument and
and then and the more we thought about
that I realize this is a feature of many
domains rights you know so I mean like
in the sort of decision-making in the
medical domain which you're very
familiar with you know if the doctor you
know applies a treatment doesn't apply a
treatment we're now in two different
worlds and we only get certain labels
about things you know if I choose you
know if I have a if I choose to hire
someone I see how they we have done in
my company if I choose not to hire them
they may go somewhere else but I'm not
gonna know how they would have done any
better in my company so often we get
these this one sided label and it's not
just randomly one-sided it's based on
the decision that the decision-making
themselves made and so the question was
how do we demonstrate some kind of you
know a gain or not through algorithms if
we only have labels in that kind of
situation and so at the at the core of
what we were doing was to exploit some
natural variation where we could
actually and so the kind of you know the
sort of few centons version of the trick
that's that's at the heart of the paper
is that in many things you have
defendants sort of as if randomly
assigned quasi randomly assigned to
multiple judges who differ in their
rates of leniency so i have a judge who
releases 80 out of every hundred people
i have a judge is 90 out of every
hundred people so now i have a new way
to release 80 out of 100 people which is
i could send them to the judge releases
90 out of 100 sort them all by risk as
compute by the algorithm then use the
algorithm to detain ten the 10 people
that finds the riskiest in that set of
90 so the judge releases 90 we
contracted back to 80 and now we have a
set of 80 defendants who we've detained
so now we have two ways to detain 80
defendants we send them to the judge who
is 80% lenient or we do this hybrid
human algorithmic rule where the human
sort of overshoots and the algorithm
scales it back and that's now an apples
to apples comparison in some sense and
yeah and there we could demonstrate
actually that there's a lower crime rate
on the hybrid human algorithmic rule
right that somehow the worst decisions
that the judge is making her pretty bad
and if you could simply fix those
you could leave most of the judges
decisions completely intact and just
basically improve at the margins and as
we're sort of intriguing to us because
it was an interesting alternative to the
dichotomy between should we have humans
do the work should we fully automate
right that's not really a binary
decision
it's really that there are cases where
the algorithm can be improving things at
the margin you say I'm gonna come in and
fix the worst decisions right
it's almost somewhere in one of our
drafts the paper we make this analogy to
you know it's you know in the realm of
cars it's seeing that we think about
human drivers or self-driving cars of
course long before we ever gotten your
self-driving cars we had all sorts of
algorithmic assistance
computer assistance in the vehicle
that's sort of preventing you from
making the worst emergency braking
exactly braking parking assist is
interesting when you're just yesterday
I'm not sure when this video be watched
but just yesterday we had a report of an
uber self-driving car with a with human
oversight killing a pedestrian
unfortunately and it's um kind of a
landmark in this kind of thing it's kind
of a kind of situation we'd been worried
about with with automation being applied
in the world and in some discussions
looks at all you know the cars will
likely save many lives I think over
36,000 last year deaths and over a
million injuries in the United States
alone and over a million worldwide we
hear if deaths from automobile accidents
and certainly these cars will even when
they're they have these rough pages will
be saving lives but there's also the
sense that when it's an automated system
there's a high standard we have for how
it behaves and videos represents
thoughts on on on what we're going with
these kinds of automation and Larry is
yeah it's so I this is a fascinating
debate I think well you know should we
hold algorithms to a higher standard and
on the way and you know there's
something appealing about saying that we
should hold algorithms to a higher
standard on the other hand you're giving
up something really tangible I mean
there are a lot of lives that who
eventually be saved if you've decided
not to hold algorithms to quite so high
a standard and so you're you're you're
paying for this decision at a high cost
and I think that's what makes this what
makes this so tricky I I do think it's
interesting I mean I've I've been sort
of trying to understand some about the
issue of you know why you know I think
you know I do
everyone I talk to you know feels this
you know this particularly strong
reaction to you know the algorithm you
know the other one caused harm you know
did something and you know I think you
know if we take you know if we take some
of the sort of pedagogical examples
where we see algorithms causing harm
where the algorithm is in a no-win
situation has to swerve left or right
and it's going to going to kill someone
or hurt someone and in those kind of
situations which are sort of awful to
contemplate humans in those situations
where it's an awful situation uh it's
very hard to say why they did what they
did something happened very fast they
tried their best
they made an essentially random decision
and something terrible happened it was
an accident as we call it
one problem with the algorithm is of
course we can go in and we can find
millisecond by millisecond what it was
doing
why you decide to turn left and not
right what was it actually thinking
about and I feel like you know if we if
we step back since we always tend to
anthropomorphize these things you know
we attach more moral opprobrium to
things that are premeditated to things
where you thought it through and you did
the bad thing anyway and and the problem
is everything the algorithm does most
New Zealanders are premeditated because
we can see what it was thinking where is
with the human at some level we'll never
know what they're thinking they were
trying their best to avoid a very very
bounded resources exactly all in real
time yeah where is the best intuitions
yeah exactly and some of the algorithm
was somehow engaging in calculation
about things where we think it's morally
questionable to engage in calculation
and and that I think is maybe part of
the reason why we ascribe but that yeah
leave nice it also certainly brings to
the to the to the into salience the fact
that at those moments for
decision-making you see uncertainty
represented potentially in an action
that was taken and an objective function
that's clear and you can state it now
and since it's a machine somewhere
yeah someone said here's the trade you
make in the situation here's the cost of
benefits yeah and so that things that
that's that that explicitness I think
also brings up questions where the
question should have been to begin with
even with implicit decision-making hey
that's the question and of course you've
you've thought a lot about these issues
but you know I do feel like a lot of
people you know
you know genuinely feel like even having
thought about it that there's some
advantage to living in a world of
strategic ambiguity where we make we
never actually calculate you know the
choice between two to terrible
alternatives so so um you've done many
different pieces of work um a lot of
them I get as you said there's these
interesting intersections looking at
communities for example communities form
on the web and and their nature and
structure how links get formed and the
power of link prediction and so on and
and some of the we see daily and now in
our in our in our various services like
Facebook and LinkedIn some comments on
on the directions there and why that's
so exciting yeah I mean if I sort of
look over the you know the sort of
longer history of this site I feel like
you know so if I back up to where we
were talking about web search circa 1996
97 you know I I think at the time you
know the conceptualization I had was
really the web is this kind of vast
Universal library of all human knowledge
and you go and you dip into the library
and you pull out knowledge from it I
feel like there was a period 2004 2006
was sort of a really important period in
the development of of the web it was
really a moment when you know that
somehow the level of participation the
technology the bandwidth had reached
mine where people could actually step
out behind their web pages and interact
more directly it was no longer I
interact with you because my web page
link to your web page it's that were
directly commenting on each other's
content and tagging each other's content
collaboratively authoring something you
know and so it was really in that scum
interactive phase transition yeah
experiential phase transition exactly
yeah and you know and a lot of the
things that we now take is sort of the
pillars of the current web all came
about right there right so in in that
you know 2 to 3 year period you know you
see the creation of Facebook YouTube
Twitter right all of them sort of you
know all of this social media sort of
you know kind of speciate or ton that
period funny mission this time I
remember being interviewed with somebody
on the work that we did which is of your
interest le as well on with your les
cubic on degrees of separation yeah and
it would created a kind of a flurry and
I remember trying to explain to a
a well-known moderator on I think it was
on CNBC what Facebook was you know what
social media was and never having to
come up with like let me explain this in
20 words or less but it had to be
explained yeah yeah it's amazing things
move so fast that things that you could
present as novelty is three or four
years later or feel like common
knowledge and it's yeah it's a main I
mean you know I you know I I remember
the first Google faculty summit they
brought us all there and we're like we
have this amazing new thing called Gmail
that offers a mega bus you know
gigabyte of storage and you know and on
the horizon is this amazing new
prototype called Google Maps you know is
and it's like that was only what you
know that has happened yeah but back to
the community the interaction yeah
exactly so I think that period suddenly
people were interacting directly and and
that surely I that struck me as a very
you know important moment and you know
even if they sent I've been think about
the web graph for 10 years up to that
point you know this idea of human social
networks now being really reflected
online you know I think it's been a very
you know a very powerful thing and you
know it it certainly brought about a new
kind of information seeking behavior a
new way in which we engage with things
where you know rather than just go out
and look for things it comes to you
through your network of friends as it
did in the offline world and you know
and obviously you know it's sort of
anytime one talks about that now you
know what has to think about sort of the
ways in which this is evolved in the
past few years where you now have this
combination of your real friends from
the offline world sharing information
with you and then commercial entities
sharing information with you
and all that somehow happening in a big
super super position this is what you're
being supposed to know online yeah now I
want to come back to that topic in a
second but of course when I write you
through thinking about some of your
contributions with your collaborators on
incentives and web activity this is a
really fabulous work on badges for
example and
understand how different kinds of
programs are reinforcing work for
example say in a crowdsourcing system or
a system where people are helping each
other get up for example how you can
actually shape but people do based on
the design of the merit program yeah a
little bit more about yeah yeah so this
was something that we became interested
in because in the in the online world
there became this proliferation of
badges if you do this much of the
activity then you got badge if you do
this much this frequently over some
period of time you get a pageant these
clearly had incentivizing effects people
people would set these as goals for
themselves and you know in some work
that uh you're a leska understand unlock
and I did you know you actually see the
effect whereas people near to milestone
their activity increased and then they
hit the milestone and it dropped off
like they're clearly aiming for that as
the finish line and so you end up with
this interesting sort of badge design
problems or a bad placement problem
where it's almost a still get people
sort of steering through the space of
activities and you know what we actually
first discovered it this way that we
were looking at just the activity as
though it was just organic activity and
we saw everyone was kind of torquing in
the strange direction in this part of
the space and you know we always felt
like sort of astrophysicists saying
there's some gravitating body here
anything that flow right we have to
figure what it is because it's invisible
to us it's some kind of dark matter
exactly and yeah and you don't go look
there's a badge right there right in
front bending around it as they try to
get me thank you telescope up this badge
coming into view in the sky you know
it's like and you know and then you you
you actually like you know plot the flow
lines in you and you would see this and
so that becomes for that those figures
in your paper magnetic filings yeah
exactly right it's like up with that
yeah and and so what's nice is you can
build some models in which yeah it's
actually in retrospect an intuitive
model that if a badge is very far away
there's a good chance I'm gonna leave
the system before it ever becomes
relevant to me if I'm very close to a
badge I'm probably gonna make it and so
it actually acquires more value and so
it actually has more drawing power the
closer I get to it almost like a sort of
you know one of these physical objects
and so it becomes a
design problem like where should I put
the pageant's right so now it's up to me
you know I'm trying to sort of create
some beautiful shape with the iron
filings I could put the magnets the
little bar magnets wherever I want and
it it it does have an effect right if I
create an incentive that comes too soon
I get everyone to participate but pretty
quickly there through the incentive and
I've lost control over them if I put too
far away it seems hopeless and there is
some kind of optimal distance at which
to put the incentive so it kind of pulls
people toward it in a way that's
achievable and so that's uh yeah so I
think there's a very interesting design
space lately so now I'll come back to an
earlier topic I thought I was gonna go
the sentence first and this is the idea
mixing these ideas of incentives and
design often we say with
well-intentioned designers who have the
users in mind or learnings or the
community in mind when they do a design
like this to other incentive other
incentives and objectives to the point
where we see the possibility in this new
connected world with all sorts of
entities including commercial entities
to do large-scale designs aimed at
manipulation which might not necessarily
be in line with the interests of the
individuals and the the prospect for
example and the possibility that some of
the best machine learning people coming
out of our departments and our
organizations now will go off and spend
time with large-scale data sets and
machine learning algorithms to optimize
time of engagement on a timeline the
duration for example or the other kinds
of behaviors on the web that might be
aimed at commerce that maximizing
profits and therefore therefore being
you know sort of there being great
incentives by entities to create
algorithmic approaches to doing
adversarial in some ways attacks on
human attention what do you think what
is going and no how might we we we
addressed this potential problem yeah so
there's obviously a mission question and
here the I think the challenges this
this problem so
and then you know I sort of hesitate to
say anything that sounds prescriptive
because I really don't think I've
thought hard about it enough to really
and I've thought pretty hard about it
but I I just feel like it's an
incredibly hard thing I should say it's
you know it is not a completely new
issue so as a child I watched a lot of
beer commercials because I liked
watching football and baseball and
because I liked football and baseball
and I was age eight I also saw lots of
beer commercial
and you guess whether that was you know
the socially optimal allocation of
people's attention but it was very much
the say the world it too was some sort
of an adversarial attack on right so you
know most professional sports was
underwritten by ultimately advertising
and so if you like professional sport or
if you liked any kind of entertainment
you were going to see a lot of
advertising and often advertising that
wasn't particularly well targeted to
your particular interests and you know
and I think that was some of the you
know the optimism around online media
that you know the things that are going
to be generating revenue ought to at
least be tailored to things that are
appropriate for you and in the end isn't
that actually a better kind of
advertising you know women so I think
you know we've always created media that
tries to optimize for engagement and try
soft noise for attention we've tended to
do it with more qualitative tools we
haven't had the kind of quantitative
like for example when we were going up
even now you know an episode of The
Twilight Zone would just hit that moment
and someone would say we'll be right
back don't you don't go away
exactly yeah yeah yeah and all of these
were you know sort of you know lower
data attempts to to get something so I
don't think that in terms of the intent
something new was happening that wasn't
happening then I think as you're saying
what what has changed is that there you
know there's much more data and
therefore much much more ability to do
really sort of you know surgically
precise interventions but I think it's
it's it's it's an activity that has sort
of been true for you know as long as
sort of humans have created media to
attract the attentions of other other
other human beings but that you know at
some point quantity becomes quality and
so I think it does does bring does
definitely new issues into play and you
know in the the extent which we should
ask you know to what extent is you know
people's immediate interest and seeking
out what kind of activates or energizes
them you know twice n should we trade
that off with long-term gain right and I
think you know that's that's not just as
a silent wrist even for the platforms
themselves in the end platforms are
perhaps less worried about whether you
spend the next one hour in the platform
and more whether you remain engaged
participant over the long term and so if
you're doing something in the short term
that keeps people you know emotionally
aroused and on the platform but in the
long run they feel bad about the
experience that's neither in society's
interest nor is it in the platform yeah
I guess you could imagine a concern
being that you do both you arouse them
and get them interested in long-term and
and five years from now someone looks
back and says boy I wish I spent my time
in a better way and so there is this
idea of you know some movements of or
some reflection at level of industry or
society more generally civil liberties
organizations yeah a time well spent
what does that mean and yeah when does
that run counter to commercial goals
with their precision manipulation slash
attack slash optimization of how they
would like to have people spend their
attention in time ya know I think it's
um it's yeah this is a very important
issue which I you know sort of I've been
thinking about more and more just
because it's it's clearly on everyone
everyone's minds but it yeah but I you
know I it is useful to think back to
everything that was said about TV and
like my generation was supposedly ruined
by all the TV that we watched you know
all the kind of mindless entertainment
the violent entertainment all the
commercials we were exposed to this was
why our country was falling behind all
the other countries it all of this I
mean I got an enormous diet of this kind
of anxiety in the 1980s and it was it
was you know because there was a media
industry that was motivated by similar
things they needed to keep an audience
that was engaged so I do think you know
as we as we think about this it's it's I
think is useful separated the parts that
are new which is how data assisted in
computational systems is from the parts
that are old which is the kind of urge
of you know people providing medium
providing content to keep their
audiences engaged you know in ways that
worry some of us so changing topics to
maybe friendlier ones and someone less
serious but but still important in terms
of time well-spent
when I visited you and give a talk I
remember in 1999 at Cornell they gave a
keynote and you hosted me and I remember
when you adopt me at the airport or back
at the hotel where I was going
you had your big bags full of hockey
equipment you and your wife yeah and
you're gonna have to play ice hockey do
you still play hockey uh I played it
less and less over yeah so I at the time
we we played twice a week and I remember
talking about it with you and we
actually should have had you play when
you were there we I think we learned
from our mistake because a couple years
later we invited John Lafferty he's a
good player and we didn't know that at
the time but he said oh he plays talking
more like perfect after so we gave the
colloquium we went to a quick dinner
didn't need too much and then we brought
him to the hockey and you know and he
had to borrow skates that didn't quite
fit
I know exactly and despite that dance
thing he stepped on the ice were like oh
wait he's really good because you know
you can tell within you know a few
seconds that someone's really good at
this and yeah so we've we definitely and
so that was a whole phase when we just
so you know I'm due out to give a talk
soon a Cornell so I'm gonna take you up
on this perfectly yeah yeah but I should
have the Sadko to this that uh over time
we've definitely didn't play you know in
that sort of yeah you know and you know
obviously sort of you know becoming
parents it's you know new time
constraints and getting busier and and
then I reached a point where I also fear
injury you know I mean like you know I'd
say in our annual intramural League
somebody would get non-trivial injury at
least once during it you know and you
know I'm definitely keenly aware that I
don't recover from things as fascism ya
know I play ice hockey also and
typically we have on a once a week team
and I have to say that do you watch
these like like popcorn you know it's
like a personal process exactly injuries
will occur and once in a while you
you walk out with an injury and ya takes
a while to recover and as you say as you
get a little older he thinks take a
little bit longer to reset ya to say oh
and then a few comments about you talked
a little bit about your background you
know having fun with the with with the
Apple 2 and then finding out this is
actually a field and having a place to
leverage your math and your inclination
to see math actually execute in the real
world you have influence and it helps to
interpret the real world what kind of
advice would you give to let's say
undergraduates now maybe finishing their
undergrad careers and how to think about
next steps yeah it's a great question
and I mean certainly I think all of us
have been you know thrilled at the level
of interest in computer science it's
just been been growing rapidly and its
enormous over the over the past few
years you know I mean it's I think one
is to really just think about how
broadly the ideas of computing can be
applied I mean I think every area either
is being influenced by the ideas of
computation or could be and so I think
you know it's it's a great opportunity
to really take this as a fundamental
body of knowledge that you can combine
with almost anything else that you find
interesting you know I mean it as I said
you know in eighth grade I want to be a
lawyer when I grew up and it took me a
very long time to finally come back and
sort of combine the computation with
that interest but in the end there's
just you know and I was sort of late to
the party people for doing it all along
but it I think you know if you have an
interest
it's almost sure to be compatible with
ideas from computing in some way and
that's just just how broad the field has
become and then I think the other thing
that you know I try to advise if I
students it's like it's easy to see in
the media how we live in an era of big
science and all science it can be done
by giant teams and your future is to be
the person who contributes one tiny data
point and some giant plot you know and I
think I can't speak for the other
sciences and what that looks like but in
computer science I think what's so
exciting is that there are still
exciting discoveries to be made you know
you and the manageable dataset and your
laptop
some new conceptual idea and you know a
lot of stuff happens still you know in
groups of you know two or three or one
with very modest resources and there are
still amazing things to be discovered
there you know obviously they're also
the stuff that happens on big data
centers you know and some of it needs
that and if if that's what you're
interested in there's this room to work
in that style but it's sort of nice to
know that you know someone working just
with a friend of theirs on a laptop can
still do things that you know attract
everyone's attractive ones attention and
that's a that's also a very appealing
thing about the field that you know the
important problems are still accessible
and some of them are quite quite
manageable for people you know who are
undergrads are just going to college
well that's a great place to stop well
thanks very much
yeah thanks a lot good talking with you